Spider-Man 2099 fights the Hulk and gets
dominated check this out so this story
takes place in the aftermath of the
spider-verse event in Marvel Comics how
fortuitous given the release of across
the spider verse so as you guys know or
at least may know from the main spy
diverse event in Marvel Comics the way
this worked is you had all the different
Spider-Man across the Multiverse teaming
up to face off against a group called
The inheritors Who quite literally
travel around the Multiverse kills
Spider-Man and then absorb their power
into themselves so at the end of this
story Miguel O'Hara was supposed to go
back to Earth 928 his home reality also
known as Marvel 2099. the difference
here is that he ended up going to a
different Universe instead specifically
when he arrives here the entirety of
Nueva York has just been completely and
totally obliterated right it's just like
this post apocalyptic landscape and even
he doesn't really even know what's going
on here right like for him it's a
complete total astonishment because his
initial thought is something popped off
while I was away and the whole of
everything has been destroyed and so
what's so crazy is that as he's here and
he's navigating this area he's suddenly
attacked by a couple of different guys
now something to understand about Miguel
O'Hara is that while he does have spider
powers his powers are not really the
result of a traditional Spider-Man which
is to say bitten by a radioactive spider
instead he's more the result of like
gene splicing right like the DNA of a
spider being spliced with his own that
gives him different abilities now Marvel
did this for the purpose of creating a
version of Spider-Man that was not
identical to Peter Parker and they could
justify why he would have varying
degrees of powers this was done back in
the 90s right so before like miles moral
Alice or those characters from Marvel
could just arbitrarily give them
whatever Powers they wanted to based on
the bite of a spider and nobody would
really bat an eye or ask any questions
but the thing about this is that where
he's attacked given the technological
nature of his suit of course he's able
to deal with this and absorb orb this
pretty quickly so him just kind of being
quote unquote knocked out or taken out
is really more just a way to kind of
lull these guys into a false sense of
security and then learn some information
but as soon as he attacks these guys one
of the things to know about Miguel
O'Hara is that the way that you saw him
depicted in Spider-Man across the
spider-verse is not wrong he's very very
similar to that in Marvel Comics he's
pretty hardcore right Peter Parker is
like the hopeful we can win no matter
what guys type Spiderman Miguel O'Hara
is kind of like I mean look right you
want to put hands on we could put hands
on but I promise you I'm gonna make it
your last fight you know what I mean
like it's that kind of a thing right
like the guy's just pretty brutal so
that's why even when he's talking to
these guys while he doesn't usually
overtly kill he threatened these guys
with the idea that he will kill them
right like talking in a pretty intense
way right and so what he starts asking
them here is what's going on here right
what happened in this place and what
they really reveal here is that one
they're what's called scanners meaning
anybody who's familiar with that term
knows exactly where Miguel O'Hara is
right now the second thing is that when
they talk about the idea of where home
is they refer to it as dystopia which
gives us the second clue right again I'm
basically telling you but I will tell
you like directly here in a second
because it's amazing so the thing about
this is he literally tells them tell me
like take me to where you come from
right take me to dystopia take me to
this place and so as they lead him back
to really their own little village the
entirety of this place is more or less
just been crushed right like there's no
one here anymore everybody seemingly
bailed out and there's no real
indication as to why nobody knows where
they went they quite literally just
vanished and so following that they
intend to really travel to dystopia only
to be set upon by like these soldiers
right now Miguel O'Hara does his normal
Spider-Man thing right bobbing and
weaving dodging that kind of thing being
able to take these guys out and then
it's just this clap that comes out of
nowhere right this Sonic hit that just
sends him flying and when he comes 2 he
sees Maestro standing over him now
here's the thing right Maestro Hulk oh
my god dude this guy's so amazing so I
know a lot of you all may not be overly
familiar with Maestro if you are bear
with me for a second because I imagine
we'll be getting new viewers who are not
the Maestro Hulk comes from a reality
called future imperfect and in fact this
is the universe that Miguel O'Hara is in
right now the nature of future imperfect
which when it was initially introduced
basically Humanity ended up destroying
itself right like nuclear war broke out
and where we didn't really know exactly
how that landscape unfolded more
recently in Marvel Comics with Maestro
war and packs and stories like that
they've basically expanded that whole
universe to show us that like Hercules
for example was one of the few people
who survived Modoc had survived as well
then Maestro Hulk killed him things
along those lines but the cool thing
about this story and and really what
goes on here is that Maestro does not
know that it's not Peter Parker now
again a lot of this is because with
Maestro's own history he once he emerged
from the entirety of his stasis and then
immediately went forward he was really
kind of killing people who got in his
way things like that he ended up killing
Hercules and then seizing control of
really the city of dystopia and then
made himself an absolute ruler that kind
of thing so he didn't exactly know who
all was out there and in fact you will
see evidence to indicate that Peter
Parker should be dead which is actually
the reason why Maestro is shocked about
everything that's going on here but
again he doesn't know that it's Miguel
O'Hara a Spider-Man from a different
reality he thinks it's Peter and in fact
Miguel O'Hara just kind of allows him to
believe that now the funny thing about
this is that Maestro starts to put
things together relatively fast right
the difference in Miguel O'Hara's outfit
things along those lines and while he
doesn't know it's Miguel he still thinks
it's Peter and so in that moment he just
kind of asked the question how in the
world did you get here and he assumes
that he time travel so one of the big
differences between Maestro Hulk and the
traditional Incredible Hulk is that
Maestro is incredibly intelligent right
he is wildly intelligent but vastly
capable now the way he was originally
depicted back in the Peter David days is
that he's the answer to the question of
the Incredible Hulk just basically
absorbing all this nuclear radiation and
just kind of going nuts again that whole
philosophy has kind of changed with like
Maestro Warren packs things like that
he's just incredibly strong right and
also incredibly smart but him deducing
this information and believing that this
is Peter Parker from The Past he simply
says if you've time traveled then here's
what's gonna happen if you want to live
once you get back to where it is you're
supposed to go you're going to bring me
with you right you're going to take me
back to your time period and that's when
Miguel O'Hara kind of cracks a joke and
says sure I'll get right on that right
I'll grab my time machine and I'll be
right back here and then Maestro
immediately attacks him now the reason
why is because Maestro is exceedingly
proud and exceedingly arrogant and he
does not suffer fools and so where
Miguel O'Hara is like cracking jokes and
doing the traditional Peter Parker thing
Maestro's not having any of it now two
degree Miguel O'Hara is kind of aware of
who Maestro is he's heard the name and
in fact he's basically been on teams
that have encountered Maestro in some
capacity but in a one-on-one knock down
drag out fight between himself and
Maestro that's never happened and in
fact even here it's not happening one of
the things he points out is how fast and
how strong Maestro is but even when Hulk
just absolutely crushes Miguel and just
starts throwing him around right like a
ragdoll one of the things that Miguel
comments on is he's not even trying his
hardest he's not even like he's
literally holding back he's not punching
as hard as he can he's not moving as
fast as he can if anything he's making
sport of Miguel and a lot of that's
because he can right whenever you saw
Maestro for example fighting like
Professor Hulk in the future imperfect
story literally when Professor Hulk went
to the Future and fought Maestro that
was a knock down drag out fight and it
was a pretty intense fight that almost
laid waste to the entirety of dystopia
this is Child's Play This is just
maestro enjoying himself but the fact
that he's able to overcome Miguel O'Hara
that easily right with seemingly the
greatest of each right with almost no
effort it's crazy because as soon as he
takes this guy out he tells us horses
bring him with me right like bring him
to dystopia now of course as Miguel is
along for the ride kind of tied down to
a to a horse the question he asks here
is what happened in this place right
like what in the world went on and the
response of maestro is it was all
basically because of alchemax now the
reason that matters here and this is
something that wasn't really focused on
at all in Spider-Man 2099 with regards
to Across the spider verse is that
within the comics alcamax is both the
main enemy of the 2099 universe but also
the company that Miguel O'Hara works for
now he works for the company but works
as Spider-Man trying to bring down the
corrupt actions of the company so
basically kind of trying to destroy his
employer and it makes sense right like
what better way to take out your enemy
than to operate right under under their
nose and so when this happens Miguel
really comes to this realization that
even if this is not the exact same
reality alchemax is the same across
every universe and that it would
presumably only be a matter of time
before they engage in some campaign in
his home reality that would lead to the
destruction of everything so of anything
it adds even a greater sense of urgency
for him to find a way to destroy alcanax
now the other part of this is that for
these two scanners that were there with
Miguel they asked the question of
maestro like where did you put our
people at like what happened to our
people and my show is like oh they're
right over here my friend let me uh let
me let me let me show you and what the
Maestro did is he basically killed them
all and then strung them all up on what
used to be the Hollywood sign but now
says Maestro right so he just kind of
used them as decoration and then he
decides to add two more pieces by
helping these guys finish with all their
living and he does that by crushing
their heads and then stringing them up
my Show's dark guys he is dark and
twisted he's amazing in this same time
but he's incredibly dark and twisted now
what ends up happening is of course once
Miguel is taken to dystopia he's
basically thrown into a cell by Maestro
and Maestro even goes as far as to say
there was a person here that I think the
two of you might be able to work
together to find some kind of solution
to everything that's going on only for
him to encounter strange from the 2099
Universe now one of the things to know
about the Marvel 299 landscape right
like Earth 928 is that because this is
the future you do have characters that
you're familiar with but in name only
for example you have Punisher 2099
that's not Frank Castle you have Venom
2099 and you also have strange 2099 now
again this is not Steven strange in fact
it's a girl named Jeannie but what ends
up going on is you have a meeting
between Maestro and what's basically his
Grand Regent or vizier if you want to
call that more of like an advisor than
anything else and literally this guy
asks the question is it a good idea to
have like this Spider-Man here shouldn't
we just kill this guy like what's your
main motivation what's your goal but the
response of maestro is it's none of your
business now a lot of this is because
Maestro again sees virtually everybody
within dystopia as below him in some
capacity some of this is due to just
straight physical strength and some of
it's also due to the level of power he
possesses and the role he plays but
regardless strange ends up meeting and
really kind of having this conversation
with Miguel and says look I'm chained up
here I do have this circle of magical
protection but in order for me to be
able to heal you you have to get close
enough which he does right like he gets
his finger close enough he kind of
shoots webbing at her which creates a
link and then that basically heals him
after that he basically breaks the bonds
they keep her chained up so now she can
be free and then in turn once the guard
shows up asking questions on what's
going on Miguel attacks them and then
they basically end up breaking their way
out of the prison now once this happens
what Genie tells him is that if he needs
to get back to his reality because the
goal of Miguel is to get back to 2015 so
he can figure out what went wrong in the
time travel hijinks that can get him
back to his normal reality now one of
the things about spider-verse is that
this was taking place at the same time
as the incursions in Marvel Comics the
collapse of all universes this is the
reason why in spider-verse when
Spider-Man UK uh William Braddock right
part of the Captain Britain Corps when
he was supposed to go back to his
Universe it was just a giant empty void
because the incursions had destroyed his
reality there was nowhere for him to go
now the incursions were an amazing story
you'll find that link down in the
comments section as well I'll have my
staff put both of those videos The
Incredible Hulk playlist and the
incursions playlist because it's just
the incursions are so cool but the thing
about this is that with the with the
Multiverse collapsing the way that it
was universe is crashing into each other
it was no longer a straight line jumping
from one Universe to the next because
the reality is that your Universe either
may not be there or it may have moved
right and so with all that happening it
was very easy for Miguel O'Hara to be
sent back to his reality but then end up
missing a turn and so the result of this
is that once they get to this room Genie
tells him inside this room is a time
travel platform right like there is a
platform here that can get you to where
you need to go now of course this is Dr
Doom's time platform but the thing here
is that once these soldiers are all kind
of taken care of right the ones who come
running in trying to stop Miguel and
Genie and so on and so forth and they
effectively get into this room it's not
just the time platform that's there it's
the trophy room of Maestro and so once
they end up grabbing the time platform
and then Miguel O'Hara basically intends
to activate it and go back to his
current time suddenly Genie's killed
right just like stabbed through the gut
only for us to find out that what
Maestro had been doing here is Maestro
had basically been hiding himself right
that what he ended up doing was using
the hood of Parker Robbins now for those
of you guys who don't know Parker
Robbins also known as the hood in Marvel
Comics he's going to be the villain in
the uh what is it the Riri Williams
Series this guy is kind of like a c-list
villain at fast but the kicker to Parker
Robbins is that he always has like some
kind of Ace up his sleeve and he's done
all kinds of crazy things but the hood
that he has allows him to be invisible
which is exactly what Maestro was doing
killing genie on the spot and then in
turn fighting against Miguel O'Hara now
he just started slapping this guy around
but again the funny thing about Miguel
is he starts using different artifacts
in this room at his disposal kind of in
this round too a good example is that he
uses a piece of the Iron Man armor from
the Hulkbuster suit to blast Maestro and
kind of take Maestro out in the moment
right now the reason why I say this is
cool and the reason why this is kind of
possible here is because the nature of
the Hulkbuster suit the way it was
designed by really Iron Man especially
when he got to Mark II was for that suit
to be able to take on world breaker Hulk
now for people who would look at this
they would kind of say okay how in the
world does it does an Iron Man suit take
out a version of Hulk this powerful well
lest we forget right assuming that the
future imperfect reality mirrors the
main Marvel Universe reality up and to
the point when everything popped off
with alcamax I don't even know if we're
given a definitive year that basically
this suit was designed for the same
purpose as it was in the main Marvel
Universe during World War Hulk it was
designed to confront and to overpower or
at least to remain an equal in power to
World breaker Hulk Maestro himself is
not as powerful as World breaker Hulk
he's incredibly capable but not as
powerful and so what this looks like in
this moment is that given the power of
the suit which still operates which is a
testament to Tony Stark's Ingenuity it's
enough to kill Maestro on the spot right
like literally incinerate this guy and
so following that Miguel O'Hara
activates the time travel portal jumps
through and then lands in 2015. switch
back over to Future imperfect right the
whole thing was a ruse the whole thing
was a trick by Maestro which is how
smart he is one this was never really
Genie as strange she's long since been
possessed by the demon that had at one
point taken over her body it was never
her operating of her own accord number
two Maestro's not dead right he was
never dead I mean that injury hurt don't
get me wrong like that shot from the
world record armor absolutely hurt but
it wasn't enough to kill him and in fact
what ends up happening is that with
Miguel O'Hara jumping through the portal
and basically powering it and so on and
so forth now it gives Maestro the
ability to use it and that's exactly
what he does he uses the time platform
and jumps back to Albuquerque on
December 25th in presumably 2015. now
the reason why this matters and what
really actually kind of sucks about this
is Maestro just kind of takes off he
will reappear in all new X Factor issue
number 20 from volume 3 which also came
out in 2015 and then that's it right
because Secret Wars happen almost
immediately after this so Maestro is
just kind of gone he doesn't reappear
until the old man Logan's story Post
Secret Wars which was an amazing story
right it was great Old Man Logan fights
the Hulk it was great you'll find a link
to that in the comment section as well
so we'll have three playlists for you to
choose from right if you want to watch
any one of them the Incredible Hulk the
uh the incursions playlist and then Old
Man Logan I would watch all three right
because they're awesome videos anyway
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you all for watching and I will
catch you all later peace